Ernest, you're a good man,
aren't you?
Yes, sir. I am. I suppose so.
You suppose so? [stammers]
Are you or aren't you?
[chuckles]
I am, sir. I am.
You love your wife and children?
Yes, sir. I do.
You served your country
in infantry and--
and I don't think
this is how your life
was meant to turn out.
Now, it seems to me
your family back home,
they're more of a blessing
to you than your uncle,
King Bill Hale.
You and I both know
he presents himself
as a very righteous man.
And that's just not who he is.
He's done nothing for you,
son...
except...
make you do bad things
and take advantage of you
because of your... disposition.
So what do you say
we start over?
I, uh...
I wanna get home to see my wife,
so you, uh...
you tell me what I gotta do.
You know who killed Henry Roan?